hello my name is steve kaufman i'm the
president of the linguist institute and
linc
i speak 10 languages i consider myself a
linguist in the sense that a linguist is
someone who enjoys speaking more than
one language i even wrote a book called
the way of the linguist
do you want to learn another language
why not try to learn like a child
a child doesn't study rules of grammar
a child listens
and by listening for a year and a half
or two years
the child learns naturally learns words
and phrases
and when the child is ready and feels
confident the child starts to use these
words and phrases
to speak
you can do the same but you can do
better because as an adult you have many
words in your own language
you as an adult can read
and furthermore as an adult you can use
link
at link you will find a great variety of
content items to listen to and read if
you are a beginner you will have you
will choose short pieces that are easy
and you will listen to them many many
many times
and read and when you read you will save
words and phrases to a personal database
and then you'll be able to review these
words and phrases using link's many
functions if you are more advanced you
needn't
listen to the same content so many times
and you can continually choose new and
interesting content to learn from saving
words and phrases and increasing your
vocabulary
soon you will feel confident enough to
speak and you'll want to speak to our
native speaker tutors or
you will want to submit writing for
correction
there are many other functions of link
please come to link i'm waiting for you
there it's both
enjoyable and efficient and i know that
at link you too will become a linguist
thank you